[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute ist samira mit dabei und wir
werden heute für den papa kochen wir
machen heute osso bucco das ist ein
mailänder rezept und spaß in das kalb
sachsen also ein sportgericht was man
wirklich super vorbereiten kann
bei uns gibt es später dazu noch ein
bisschen risotto und samira bekommt dazu
nudeln gelb und dieses mal gericht
besteht zum einen aus kalbsfleisch da
ist noch gemüse mit dabei eine richtig
leckere soße und ihr könnt es wirklich
gut vorbereiten und dann einfach in den
ofen schieben und habe wirklich ein
tolles mittag oder abendessen
ich zeige euch mal die zutaten
christopher böck verwende ich vier kalb
sachsen scheiben sprache olivenöl 2
zwiebeln eine knoblauchzehe zwei jahren
drei staudensellerie ich habe etwas salz
und pfeffer einen esslöffel mehl etwas
tomatenmark und gemüsebrühe
das ist jetzt wieder so ein rezept
braucht man wirklich super vorbereiten
kann
und jetzt frage ich zuerst einmal alles
in einem topf an ich nehme jetzt hier
einfach meinen kummer topf den den kann
ich später auch in den backofen schieben
aber dann sportfreunde zum beispiel auch
nehmen
ich erhielt setzt den topf und da kommt
die hälfte vom olivenöl rein und sobald
das olivenöl heiß ist kommen hier die
herzen scheiben rein
die sind etwa 3 cm dick
ich mache doch immer nur zwei reihen und
berate sie von jeder seite vertreibungen
scharf an
also wirklich schön bei hoher hitze und
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
das gemüse vorbereiten
da wir bereits aus zwiebeln geschält und
die knoblauchzehe und die werden einfach
in feinen scheiben geschnitten also die
hebel in hall bringen und die
knoblauchzehe entscheiden
[Musik]
das kann ich auch schon die möhren
vorbereiten das grünliche zwecks ist
nämlich immer ganz gerne das motiv also
nichts wegschmeißen oder einfach im
salat geben und die schneide ich jetzt
einfach längst einmal durch und
schneidet sie dann in etwas zwei
zentimeter große stücke
[Musik]
und dem sellerie schneide ich dann auch
noch ganz rein
zwischendurch auch das fleisch auf leben
und das richtige fleisch ein
[Musik]
meistens weiß butter angebraten und ich
habe eine assistentin dass wir gewonnen
da kann man etwas öl das restliche öl in
den topf wenn wir auf sie zurück und die
knoblauchzehe dazu geben
ich stelle mir auch die hitze ein
bisschen runter so auch mit dem hof
stück halt immer ein bisschen her
jetzt frage ich die zwiebeln und den
knoblauch stücke für etwa drei minuten
an
[Musik]
jetzt in die zwiebeln angebraten jetzt
kommt hier das tomatenmark dazu und das
nähe schön einrühren
[Musik]
kurz mit anbraten schön dass ich alles
gut verbinden nicht lecker gern richtig
schöne rest aromen und jetzt vorsichtig
einen schritt zurück nicht das was auf
dich spritzt jetzt habe ich hier die
gemüsebrühe ihr könnt natürlich auch ein
teil von der gemüsebrühe einfach mit
weißwein zum beispiel ersetzen
es ist dann immer so schön
[Musik]
und so lösen sich dann auch alle
bestandteile noch mal vom topfboden den
neuwieder dann weiß man das einmal kurz
aufkochen und jetzt haben irgendwann
sehen
die meiste arbeit schon getan den rest
erledigt gleich der baku
[Musik]
zumal jetzt kocht die soße schon was
mache ich denn heraus jetzt kommt das
fleisch wieder rein
da kommt jetzt noch das gemüse obendrauf
so kleiner dieb und jetzt könnt ihr
gerne an der stelle noch abdecken mit
salz und pfeffer
ich hatte aber die früher schon
ordentlich gewürzt jetzt kommt hier der
deckel drauf und dann darf das en vogue
für etwa eineinhalb stunden in den
backofen bei 160 grad und in der
zwischenzeit können wir schon mal für
sanierer passt besser zu machen und
trifft einfach mit deckel garen und in
dem kupfer talks gab das auch ganz gut
ansonsten nehmen wir einfach mit mir als
nudeln kochen jetzt hier bereits die
sind auch gleich gas emiraten schon
hunger ich werde jetzt noch ein risotto
zubereiten risotto alla milanese dass
man dazu sagen risotto kann man auch im
topf kochen aber man muss natürlich die
ganze zeit ständig hören also dass man
wirklich 20 25 oder 30 minuten damit
beschäftigt den risotto reis zu rühren
ich mache das ganze deswegen jetzt in
der kennwort cooking chef
wir können natürlich auch das risotto
einfach im topf kochen und daneben
rühren ich sage ich mal kurz die zutaten
für das risotto alla milanese verwende
ich 300 gramm risotto reis eine zwiebel
40 gramm butter
hier habe ich parmesan safranfäden
gemüsebrühe salz und pfeffer ich werde
zuerst einmal den parmesan nehmen und
den reibe ich jetzt ganz kurz
den kann ich jetzt schon zur seite
stellen jetzt nehme ich die butter die
kommt ihr direkt in den topf und kann
geschmolzen haben
[Musik]
jetzt kommt hier noch der regel wirklich
rein da was koche element und die
zwiebeln und jetzt kann ich die zwiebeln
darin ein bisschen an haben
[Musik]
jetzt sind die zwiebeln angebraten ich
habe jetzt auch die hitze weg und jetzt
arbeite ich einfach mit dem ressort
programm als ich gehe hier an darauf
programme dann auf herzhaft hauptgericht
risotto
jetzt steht hier choräle mit einsätzen
das habe ich ja schon um regel für die
zutaten zu geben also jetzt risotto reis
treiben
safran dazu ich habe jetzt hier noch die
gemüsebrühe ihr könnt dann natürlich
auch im teil ersetzen mit weißwein zum
beispiel
[Musik]
ich lasse das risotto jetzt einfach hier
drin kochen wenn ihr mal sehen wollte
wie es auf dem herd mache dann schreibt
einfach in die kommentare
dann können wir gerne auch ein paar
weitere resultate machen
[Musik]
dies ist der reeser tor eis gleich
fertig jetzt kommt noch der parmesan
dazu und dann können wir gleich alles
servieren
der papa darf jetzt probieren wir machen
jetzt mal hier das risotto in einem ring
so oder so eine ich weiß ich mich eine
ganz ganz toll getroffen
kann man damit komplett direkt die
karosse buckow heißt übrigens knochen
mit loch weil eben hier in der mitte
dieses loch treis okay ja aber das lag
als ist ein leckerer als ich sagt hat
also genug ist nämlich auch dabei
natürlich gemüse ist ganz legal sein
lehrer
man kann noch so eine cremona tor dazu
machen nochmal mit staudensellerie und
zitronen abrieb aber probiere es einfach
mal erst zeigen
ok
aber ich bin auch er ist ja okay es aber
nicht werden gekocht noch ein bisschen
pfeffer daher ein bisschen wird man noch
ein bisschen salz jetzt noch gar nicht
probiert so noch kein salz drauf weil es
wegen ein paar mehr sagen okay zwischen
messe schutz also ich probiere das
risotto
das risiko ist mir gesagt dass er mich
so oft du willst und geredet jetzt ich
sage die partie birgt ja also wenn ich
jetzt auch nicht so richtig gemacht habe
wie ihr das spiel kein ressort experte
muss man auch nicht so sagen wow ich
habe es einfach in der kirche maschine
im durchschnitt ich lieb dich zwar habe
ich wollte mich eine halbe stunde lang
restaurieren auf dem herd sich du
brauchst doch gar kein messer
ich muss schwurgericht muss zu fahren da
braucht die recht kein messer oder sich
richtig cool also ist vergeht auf der
zunge noch echt cool gemacht mich nicht
an bord
und jetzt als gemüse freigelegt
das muss es auch essen oder probierte
ich bin ja total salami fans also ich es
staudensellerie austragen so mit tipps
und was was auch die kunst dabei ist das
fleisch zart zu machen und das gemüse
trotzdem bissfesten wenn das gemüse
nicht bisher also wenn es das gemüse
auch so zerfällt dann ist so eine
matsche pampe das knochenmark in der
mitte das erste produkt der lenkertasche
ja und dass ich nicht so ja ich mag das
nicht ich weiß dass meine eltern haben
das immer gemacht wir haben das knoten
mag so rausgezogen paragrafen ich weiß
es und ich finde es furchtbar und dann
hört sich das so an
also dieses rezept ist wirklich
empfehlenswert falls erst mal nachmachen
wollt könnt ihr auf meinem blog noch mal
vorbeischauen auf 6 - blog.de
da stehen die ganzen mengenangabe
kurator hat getestet das ist gut so
wirklich nichts macht auch sagen du
kannst es auch kochen
es komme also wird beim nächsten mal
[Musik]
einfach so was tun gegen den herbstblues
ich hol den sommer zurück indem ich was
sommerlich fruchtiges backe sally verrät
ihr rezept ich backe bizkit rolle und
macht daraus eine charlotte und dann
mache ich noch cake pops ausland
dann mache ich noch im sommer getreten
danke sommerlaune aufkommt
einfach seine sonntag 16 uhr bei vox